[Music]
it's good to be back here i'm your host
patrick bett david
ladies and gentlemen we're live are we
really so you're the opening voice is
that what it is moving
forward did you decide yourself did you
just hire yourself walking around
restaurants bumping into women pissing
them off
and we got 135 watching today keep this
in mind that we're doing it on this
channel we are officially in florida we
want to tell what city we're in or we
can tell them what city we're we are in
boca raton
with our good friend who is back biz doc
aka tom ellsworth not the other way
around biz doc also known as tommel's
tom over and our guest today is my
friend steve murphy
we got gerardo gerard michaels on with
us special guest adam's best friend in
the world ricky aguilar how are you
doing rick i'm doing good how about you
guys what's up kevin
the one and only ronan
from call of duty aka two land we have a
special guest today michael francis we
have sammy devel garvano here with us
today bernard carrick john styles david
harris jr how are you doing tom center
in the house good morning we have our
good friend daniel demartino with here
with us morning phil heath just walks in
come on infield i'm making some rules
that's how you make an engine
the one and only
chance parliamentary aka sunny the first
thing
what is the soy boy
so i found
i found that up
[Music]
you should search that on youtube
instead of doing it here media not media
media yeah media matters oh kai from
norway t-h-u-r
kai t-h-u-r
oh my gosh kai just type in
you tell kai to taipei he types me he's
sleeping over there
that's a great you said superman
unbelievable
okay epstein
okay it's gonna be all right buddy
[Music]
happy birthday patrick
[Music]
whatever prediction go the opposite
route
said marilyn monroe was in bed with
bobby kennedy and she started yelling my
name
what are you smiling about it might
happen to you
they're chad's i can't i got kids i
totally understand that don't worry
about it you know i'm just a little
desperate right now call all five of
them seven of them up wow and i asked
him for money
boom as soon as i got to check they
couldn't ask me for money of course
you see this right here this is the crux
of all the issues gentlemen
this right here she's a latina from the
bronx ain't got no booty that is the
that's what's happening here
she needs to she wants to
be canceled don't do all the drugs now
later by the way like your opinion man
[Music]
lincoln once said don't believe
everything you read on the internet
i don't know if you guys know that it's
very factual it's true
it's true
by the way youtube we're joking if he
came out and he was like they were like
why did you go to outer space and he was
like plus i could [ __ ] i've been like
this is the coolest dude on earth bye
bye
bye bye
bye
[Music]